in this current virus pandemic we're all
being told to change our lifestyles
dramatically they should not feel normal
for you right now but do you know your
social distancing from your self
isolation what about being in quarantine
well here's what it all means social
distancing is staying away from other
people as much as possible you must stay
at home some places are calling it stay
at home or shelter-in-place
but it all means the same thing if you
have to go out for supplies or a bit of
fresh air you need to keep two metres
between yourself and others the governor
said it's okay to go outside so here we
are as long as we stay sealed apart
avoid touching public surfaces and wash
your hands before and after you
shouldn't be socializing with your
friends or family if you do you're risk
spreading the virus to vulnerable people
social distancing is for every healthy
person even if they don't show signs of
coronavirus it is a war well then act
like it's a war self-isolation means not
leaving the house at all and maybe even
avoiding people in your own house this
is the old wall city in the city of
Bergamo it is an empty it looks it but
it isn't it's full of people but they
are all self isolating in the UK if you
have a continuous cough or a fever you
should be in self isolation for seven
days from when your symptoms started the
Prince of Wales has tested positive for
coronavirus and if you live with anyone
they should go into self isolation for
14 days from when your symptoms started
the Duchess of Cornwall does not have
the virus the Prince and the Duchess are
now self isolating this is because their
symptoms might take a few days longer to
show if they've caught the virus from
you if you're in self isolation I will
remain in self isolation for 14 days
there are teams of volunteers
lots of communities who can help you get
food and supplies quarantine has the
same effect as self-isolation but it's
about managing risk if you travel from a
country that has a corona virus outbreak
the government may us either quarantine
the last thing that any one of us would
have wanted is to have passed that virus
on if we were infected to pass it on to
somebody else the rules vary from
country to country
so check local government advice if
you're in quarantine you need to follow
the same rules as self isolation no
contact with other people except in an
emergency the specifics of each of these
terms changes from country to country
from midnight tonight we bunker down for
four weeks as the situation changes so
will the government advise the time has
now come for us pool to do more so it's
worth keeping up to date with what your
government wants you to do and don't
forget to wash your hands